hi there reach technician I'm Gregg
elbow and I'm Katrina Alicia Katrina
Alicia's returning with us this time the
three of us are in a video together
Avengers ignite speaking of Avengers we
are going to cover a video from one of
my personal favorite channels that I
actually didn't discover until like six
months ago called new rock stars they're
a fantastic challenge sure you guys have
heard of them before they are doing very
well on the internet and they have a
video here called marvel face for -
what's next question mark comic-con 2019
preview by the way I'm going to
comic-con gonna be hosting a panel so
you should come by and say hi Friday
July night did yeah this is a top reward
video request from our man Jason Dolan
so you know what guys behind us in
looking ahead past spider-man far from
home Marvel fans have now found
ourselves in an unfamiliar sensation
uncertainty comes next
still very much a mystery and not a fun
mystery like a scroll search or Spidey
duck hunt so helpless we'll be returning
to Hall H at Comic Con
yeah during which kind of guy he will
presumably make a little cameo to
announce the marble baseball lineup in
schedule just like you did in October
2014 back when we all still believed
Feige about that Inhumans movie that
never happened oops fair I'm gonna break
down with that lineup revealed at Comic
Con might be and everything we know at
this point about the future of the moral
Cinematic Universe
immediate release that we're waiting for
information about is Disney's upcoming
streaming service Disney which will
launch on November 12 2019 there are
currently 5 Marvel related series that
will stream on Disney Plus Dalkon and
Winter Soldier will begin production in
October 2019 and is set to premiere on
the service in August of 2020
it'll star Anthony Mackie asbestos
ultimate reality caps there will also be
Marvel what if an anthology series based
that's what I'm most excited for
that will also come out within the first
year of the service with a pilot episode
focusing on what if Peggy Carter
received this equals a marble streaming
service one division a series with
Scarlet Witch envision that will begin
production in fall 2019 as well and the
Loki series was announced with Rick and
Morty writer Mike Waldron to produce
with the premise being Loki affecting
events throughout human history and this
will come out in the center center of
the service probably sometime in 2021
meanwhile we are still waiting on
details for an untitled Hawkeye series
that sounds like it'll feature Clint
sparks and mentoring Keith Bishop but
when it comes to major theatrical
releases the only movie Marvel has in
production from what we know is Black
Widow Scarlett Johansson will star as
Natasha Romanov and what will likely be
a 2006 prequel in Budapest coast are
influenced by Yelena Bulova as well as
Rachel Weisz David Harbour ot that
bed-leg characters like Hawkeye and Nick
Fury could also make cameos cake
Shortland its directing and this could
be the movie that Marvel planned for its
mystery May 20-22 be guardians vol 3 but
the James Gunn drama delayed that
release so a more like what chase
because you know would probably be in
November 2012 the next movie in the
Marvel pipeline is the Eternals
the Marvel Comics the Eternals were an
offshoot of the process that created
sentient life on earth the Celestials
created the Eternals initially to defend
earth and that led to a war between the
Eternals and the deviants Angelina Jolie
will star as Cersei in a plot that has
been described as a love story with the
character Icarus who's gonna be played
by Richard Madden aka Robb Stark Johnny
ma dongseok and Soma Hayek Chloe's now
it's directing and it's speculated that
this could release sometime in summer
2010 thickly night is the second black
panther film director Ryan Coogler is
returning in the plan is to start
production in late 2019 or early 2020
which could mean a February 2021 release
remember in Avengers endgame the first
characters to portal into that final
battle or who to Tallis Cherie in Ocoee
so that could be a sign for these
characters be the priorities for
Marvel's features that would amazed to
know that a Doctor Strange film is in
the works
scott derrickson will direct once again
and see Robert Cargill is coming back
script production is set to begin in
2020 and this could be another summer
2021 release or perhaps a November 2021
release after the first Doctor Strange
came out in 2016 Erickson said that he
was interested in nightmare as a future
villain and if he followed Erickson on
Twitter which I highly suggest that he's
a fascinating follow he's in to post
some cryptic horror influences of his
and images from the Doctor Strange
comics that could indicate some kind of
cosmic and David Callahan writing the
script that the goal is to avoid Asian
stereotypes that a direct adaptation the
comics like run into loony Lin and
rattler are speculated to be considered
for the lead role and production will
begin after production for the Eternals
wraps so we might be seeing a shang-chi
movie dropping sometime early 2020 - and
that brings us to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 now James Gunn has been
rehired to direct but thanks to all that
stupid drama last summer production was
delayed to get James Gunn time to direct
Suicide Squad to virgin see in time for
the rest of the cast schedules to line
up since this is very much lanza the
movie and everyone needs to have time to
work together I'm thinking we might be
looking at a summer 2022 release or this
one now coming out of endgame who
suggested that it could be a possible as
guardians of the galaxy team-up would
not happen why James Gunn tweeted to
stop calling it as guardians of the
galaxy which might mean Thor won't be in
this movie or gun just distantly puns in
the title gun has said that he wants the
third movie to focus on the mystery of
Rockets origin perhaps related to the
characters our important in a
post-credits scene for volume 2 Adam
warlock will almost certainly factor
into the story and of course we know at
some point there will be a third Tom
Hollands spider-man film probably with
some home related title like can't go
home after homecoming yeah the poster HD
for far from home indicates a possible
direction the third movie could go and
say my breakdown of the post credits
scenes for details on that and similarly
will probably get a second Captain
Marvel film which the apart from on post
credits scenes also might have shed some
light on again check out that breakdown
but I'm guessing these second film will
introduce the adult mom
Rambow AKA spectrum who is established
as a child in the first one all of this
said Kevin Feige would be nuts if he
didn't plan on some major tentpole
crossover film considering phase 3
included Civil War infinity war and
endgame my bet is that we really see an
Avengers secret invasion announcement
maybe Secret Wars and/or an introduction
the Fantastic Four and along with these
other titles I've mentioned there are
several Marvel characters that can be
has brought up as possible future films
this includes Nova whom Peggy has named
and director Adam McKay mentioned as a
film being developed psyches also
mentioned Connelly Khan Mubi the future
first Muslim American superhero in the
MCU consumer Noah Hawley has said that
he's written exam the new script
admirable students are still in
discussions with him about it according
to reports some character in this new
marble face war will probably be played
by Keanu Reeves in what major Avengers
tentpole events you want to happen
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at a
boss and subscribe to the rockstars or
breakdowns and theories about everything
Marvel related thank you for joining me
[Music]
okay well guys make sure to go subscribe
to new rock stars if you haven't already
they're one of the best channel so I've
ever existed yeah you know Jason Dolan
posed a question to us of wanting us to
guess the release date of the film's you
know I'm not gonna even gonna try to to
do something different than a post
guardians three first first that's the
main one right away then all the new
stuff and then we're gonna cap it off
with the sequels to Doctor Strange and
guardians 1 the thing with guardians was
they're talking about the as guardians
of the galaxy a lot of people have been
wanting there to be you know a Thor to
be included in there after what happened
in any game I personally wouldn't want
that because I don't think that was part
of James Gunn's original script it is is
supposed to complete the trilogy of the
Guardians
I feel like Thor would ultimately steal
the show
that's not to say I wouldn't want a
movie with Thor and the guardians of the
galaxy's I just don't think it should be
the closing trilogy chatroom yeah
exactly thing is he could just make an
appearance you know and then not good
enough Julian you could directly harken
back in some kind of fun intro sequin
like the part two intro basically waste
time being a music video you can have
authority of you want that's true we'll
just be fun to see him in it at least he
would definitely steal the show it's
Thor I think other people would show up
for less for the Guardians story though
because I like the idea of exploring
Rockets origin story that's something
that we haven't really dive deep into
but I remember from the first guardians
movie when he's giving that speech in
the bar that was one of the moments that
actually made me tear up when you're
hearing a little bit about his
background and they mentioned that I was
like oh yeah they really haven't
actually explored much of the intricate
details of what went on there and I
think that would be a good right step
for heart three to conclude everything
for these Disney Plus shows though
Katrina which one are you most excited
for but also I mean all of them for
different reasons but I just always
loved Loki's mischief and all the
shenanigans he gets into so it's funny
they're getting the Rick and Morty John
jump in here would you you know Rick and
Morty fan you buy friggin more yeah
that's it yeah okay I'll let you guys
handle this what are you guys thinking
I'm working on my moderating skills for
Comic Con what do you guys think about
the the thing with having a person who's
a producer creative head on Rick and
Morty come over to help helm the new
Loki series that deals with time travel
mm-hmm I highly doubt that expertise
will make that much of a difference I
highly doubt that we will see Marvel
infused with anything any approaching
Rick and Morty type humors very
different out there in crass and weird
and heavily improved sure but Rick and
Morty does get really sci-fi and it does
get pretty emotionally intense some of
the times so I feel like yeah Loki of
all the characters to have a Rick and
Morty mind on is the one
as crass as Rickon already is it's still
a really smart show done very well
written very well and I feel like that
could be taken and put a little bit into
low-key excuse me one second hey Siri
what does crass mean I would say that as
crass as Rick and Morty can be and
whatever the hell you said at the end
but the Disney Plus shows Bucky and
Falcon that actually sounded more
exciting to me before the end of endgame
because they announced that before we
watch it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then Falcon gets the the shield and you
know he's gonna be helping the Captain
America mantle or is he too much
pressure I felt like man you finally get
a new guy to be Captain America black
dude if it's continuing in that path it
seems like that's the only way it would
actually fit this whole timeline you
know I thought it would be cool I'm just
trying to be woke Michigan is a movie
this room see personally I am most
excited for the what-ifs just because
that's what I've been praying at hoping
for since the big comic book boom of our
you know past decade again is like I
love those stories often the most
because there is a lot of purism to
comic book lore so like yeah to get the
Marvel characters it seems like DC is
already kind of starting that to have an
anthology environment for Marvel to do
that I think is actually the most
exciting to me more more so than any
honestly of the movie characters getting
shows sure all right
what endgame proved is taking character
like getting a professor Hulk in there
or getting a fat Thor in there they
could really make that work see Katrina
like which character out of the MCU
would you like to see a what-if stake on
I really need to take classes at the
ground probably spider-man yeah I was
guessing probably spider-man how so what
would be the what if I mean if I'm being
completely honest I don't know a whole
lot about the what-ifs like that whole
side of that's that's the whole point of
it what is what is anything I would want
to do the version that's like Cronenberg
where he actually becomes a main spider
yeah yeah they should do like a right
version of that yeah where he's like
horrifying but still super hero yeah
that's true so are you guys excited for
the Black Widow moving a little too late
to be excited right like you said it's
like after endgame it feels yeah it's
not that I don't want her story it feels
weird to do one now why do you like that
that was the biggest missed opportunity
of the first why didn't we do that yeah
it feels like too little too late for
the effort how important it would have
been for them to make it and there's and
there seem to be like the creatives had
to come out and speak about how why at
the end of endgame she wasn't really
being honored even with spider-man far
from home it's all about Tony Stark and
there was like a mention of Black Widow
and Captain America like a little like
but there's not even much like honor
going towards Black Widow there so I you
know it just seems like okay yeah I
guess about time I wonder how well it
would do that I actually that is one
doubt I have is I wouldn't be fully
surprised if it didn't ultimate perform
all that well consider it would be the
first time the MCU is doing a full-on
prequel you know the Captain Marvel
might take place in an earlier time
period before equal this would be their
first prequel either way the people have
been wanting this movie forever so I'm
sure those fans are thinking it's
delayed so delayed yeah I would have
cared a lot more if it came out unless
they're going to commit to that and
start doing like a bunch of stories from
the past featuring characters we know
and have these like weird sidequest
movies or something like that but I feel
like honestly it would have made more
sense to do a Black Widow show I would
like to see that would be cool I would
like to see a what ifs
take on black panther if he was white
that would be fascinating fascinating
fascinating
of course you white people without
here's me white a baby an ambassador
I get a little Moses now be great we
must elevate this special white baby for
no good the Eternals is getting a lot of
talk right now for huge Marvel comic
readers I've never read any of the
eternal what gets me excited about the
little bit of information I know about
you know MCU has been pretty clear that
they're gonna be going a lot more cosmic
the Eternals though it seems like it
will be more in the direction of what
Thor was more established as and sort of
like the gods of the universe because
you know it's like yeah we have
guardians we have Captain Marvel
Ragnarok even seem to shift a little bit
away from gods element into like sci-fi
cosmic territory which is always has
been the Eternals I think we could bring
it back into expanding upon the gods of
the universe time deal which would
excite me and going to sort of an epic
fantasy revived instead of you know
something we're more familiar with I
feel like the Thor movies tried to go to
epic fantasy try to go to Lord of the
Rings you know that kind of calendar
route but yeah didn't quite find the
balance
so maybe Eternals could do something
like that and that's what did they see
Angelina Jolie
yeah sure probably has like a little
role she's probably a really good
character a good person great I wish
that the new phase would start with
Black Panther 2 honestly I kind of feel
like that would be the most if there's
not time but that would be the most
sensible thing to me cuz it's like a
beloved character people want to see
again I feel like coming back in with
somebody either really new or pretty
familiar but pretty fresh would be the
way to kick things off Doctor Strange I
know you're a big fan of your big fan
dr. IRA Doctor Strange yes sad like
Doctor Strange I didn't love him
honestly until infinity war that's the
character because of infinity war I'm
more excited for Doctor Strange to now
then as opposed to if it just came after
the first one would know infinity war an
endgame in between shang-chi that's when
I'm very much excited for a lot of
people praised the fight choreography of
black iron thirst Iron Fist yes I know
it's between Lew dealin and
oh and Ross Butler from Riverdale wasn't
he also in shazam yeah are you guys
paying attention
weirdly shang-chi is one of the ones I'm
most looking forward to out of all this
again like the new characters and the
new it's something yeah excited I don't
like the idea that I'm trying to you
know dim down Asian stereotypes though
considering the fact that I'm Asian I
love when the stereotypes are I play
mulan is the best animated disney movie
foo manchu great great franchise yeah
the original mandarin i was upset that
the original mandarin they change with
the Ben Kingsley version this is going
nowhere Asian stereotypes guys yeah
ironic love for Asian serious
discussions longer than the video we
reacted thanks for watching make sure to
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification about the gun out of hubba
nobody have a video up
check out Katrina on social media she's
a part of the fan Terri part of the fan
13 Theory TV damn straight yes Jason
Dolan thanks for requesting this my dude
Katrina this is a good guy for you to
know he's a screenwriter Oh Katrina
wants to be a successful oscar-winning
actress so Jason if you're looking for
some talent here
Jason is also single but you could play
tonically interact and respect one you
know like this guy what to do Katrina